- [TARAJI] This is the part of the show
where Kelly shares something wonderful
from the world of social media.
Now it's my turn.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
One thing to know about
me, I'm a hair chameleon.
That's my personality,
from braids, knots, to
body weaves and blowouts.
I've done it all.
And it's led me to create my own line
of products called TPH by Taraji.
That's why I'm excited
about this next story.
Three sisters in Buffalo, New York
have opened the city's
first black female owned
beauty supply store.
It's called The Hair Hive.
The sisters are dialed in, but, get this,
(Taraji laughs)
they think they're talking to Kelly.
Let's surprise them.
Surprise!
- Hi!
[TARAJI] (laughing)
Hi, Lauren, Brianna, and Danielle. Hi!
How are you?
Obviously, Kelly's not here today.
So, she invited me to host her show,
and I'm excited to talk to you guys.
Congratulations on the store.
This is huge!
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- It wasn't easy, was it?
- It was not easy at all.
We actually opened in March of 2020
and we had to close just a
month later due to the pandemic.
So, we really had to shift
and figure out how can we be successful
in a pandemic that we
didn't know was coming.
So we started selling PPE in our store,
essential products for the pandemic,
and were able to open
and be designated as
an essential business.
And it kinda propelled us
in a different direction,
because a lot of people that
didn't know we were here,
started coming to our store
because we were the only
beauty supply store open.
- Yeah, not only were we essential
because, you know, it was
the middle of a pandemic
but we kind of designated
ourselves as essential
because we were a black
owner in the community,
and we actually had representation out.
- That's amazing.
I'm gonna let you ladies know,
I kept my local beauty salon store afloat
the entire pandemic.
- She looking for me now.
I'm like, "Girl, I'm back at work."
"I can't come in."
What I love is that you also
teach classes to the community.
Is that right?
Tell us about that.
- Yes. And we do, we have
a nonprofit organization
called "The Hair Hive Learning Lab"
and it's for ages 12 to 17.
It's a six week course and it is free
but we do run on donations
from the community and beyond
and we teach, weaving,
cutting, braiding, dying
all of that.
And we also teach you how
to start and run a business.
- [TARAJI] Oh my goodness, ladies.
That is beautiful.
Thank you so much, Lauren,
Brianna, and Danielle.
I'm liking your post
right now. That's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2.
The go-to pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor ultimate
overachievers, just like you.
So they'll be writing
you a check for $1,000.
- Wow!
- [TARAJI] One more thing, one more thing.
As a female entrepreneur, I
love the work you're doing
with the store and the community.
That's the biggest part
for me, teaching babies
how to make wigs, honey. I love it!
That's why I want to send you
the entire TPH collection
to use in your classes.
Including, we have two
new products coming out.
We have a masking and relaxing
charcoal mask for the scalp
and we also have no brass,
which is the blue toner
for when you're dying your hair.
So you will be the first
to get the two new products
included with the larger line.
And I'm also gonna reach
out to you personally
for something else coming from
me personally, a check baby.
So stay tuned.
Okay?
For me, TPH is a labor of love.
So I know entrepreneurship isn't easy.
But when you have passion, drive,
and dedication and pour your blood, sweat
and tears into it, anything is possible.
Please keep going, Queens. Please.
I'm gonna get your information.
I got some more stuff coming for you.
I love you so much.
- Thank you so much.
- [TARAJI] Take care.